mit industrie wird sich nun fordert
sebastian lege den sternekoch frank
buchholz zum geschmacks duell heraus
sebastian möchte wissen ob sein turbo
oder die luxusversion vom sternekoch den
schnabel vorne hat industrie ware
schmeckt oft viel besser als der preis
vermuten lässt möglich macht das eine
zutat namens würze geschmacksverstärker
wie glutamat sind zwar unbeliebt doch
versteckt den wohlklingenden zutaten die
hefeextrakt finden sie sogar in bio ware
verwendung vor allem bei fertiggerichten
dank industrie würze schmeckt auch
minderwertiges fleisch lecker
zum beweis fordert sebastian lege den
sternekoch und fleisch experten frank
buchholz zum grill duell
frank sebastian sroka so der
lebensmitteltechnologe behauptet er
bekommt das billig huhn vom discounter
genauso lecker hin wieder spitzenkoch
sein edel geflügel
meine großmutter war ein metzger
satiniert immer gesagt günstige mädchen
taugen nichts mehr sage ich ihr diese
weiber die sind meiner meinung nach
nichts wert
aber ist natürlich dass sie eine
preisfrage was kostet was kostet ein
münchen im kino bestimmt deutlich teurer
als das das geht ja damals nur einmal
zweimal dreimal teurer das wird mir
schon recht ich würde sagen firma teurer
viermal teurer heißt im klartext so ein
französischer luxus gockel kostet mit
haut und knochen jeweils zwölf euro pro
kilo
sebastian nehls pure hühnerbrust vom
discounter gibt dagegen für weniger als
vier euro pro kilo
klar das fleisch nicht dieselbe qualität
doch diesen nachteil soll nun bewerte
industrie zutaten wieder ausgleichen
als da wären wasser salz flüssiges
raucharoma für die grill note und
natürlich hefeextrakt für einen
intensiveren fleischgeschmack das habe
ich ein bisschen hefeextrakt ist dann so
nach dem untermarkt die nächste
erfindung gewesen um den leuten so einen
vollmundigen geschmack zu erzeugen man
kennt das aus dieser kleinen flasche die
ganz gerne zur ersten super g und kg
hefeextrakt drei euro
ein bisschen wasser ein bisschen rauch
also falls mal kostenoptimierung
konzentrierte würze fleischgeschmack
ohne fleisch die erfindung dieses
prinzips war so etwas wie der big bang
der lebensmittelindustrie in den 1800
50er jahren erfindet justus von liebig
ein verfahren aus fleisch konzentriertem
extrakt herzustellen
eine riesiger verkaufserfolg
doch dann macht ein junger schweizer
namens julius maggi die entdeckung
seines lebens das gleiche verfahren
funktioniert auch mit getreide schroth
stunden lang gekocht in salzsäure
zersetzt mit natronlauge neutralisiert
heraus kommt eine salzige brühe mit
herzhaft fleischigen geschmack ganz ohne
teures fleisch für millionen menschen
ein riesiger fortschritt heute eine
zutat mit der die industrie fleisch aus
massenproduktion geschmacklich aufpeppt
damit sie ihre wirkung optimal entfaltet
spritzt läge die flüssig würze ins
fleisch
ein beliebter trick um neben geschmack
auch zusätzliches gewicht und damit mehr
profit zu erzielen
sternekoch frank buchholz mit grausen
seine gäste erwarten da schon mehr da
sieht auf jeden fall nicht unbedingt
viel versprechend aus fleisch das
wahrsagen
in der edel gastronomiezelt naturgemäß
nicht der günstige preis sondern das
besondere und dazu gehört für frank
buchholz auch die haltungsform der tiere
120 tage hatte sei nun zeit zu wachsen
und schmackhaftes fleisch zu entwickeln
viermal mehr als hühner aus dem schnell
mastbetrieb deshalb vertraut buchholz
voll auf den natürlichen geschmack mehr
als eine ordentliche prise salz braucht
sein vogel nicht dann kommt er so wie er
ist auf den grill jetzt möchte ich mal
sehen was der tage drauf hast die das so
weitergehen mit der ganzen spritzerei
das wird spannend
das kann man wohl sagen denn sebastian
läge so genannte grillhähnchen bekommen
niemals einen grill zu gesicht
stattdessen garen sie bei 120 grad im
ofen damit möglichst viel vom
aufgespritzten gewicht erhalten bleibt
[Musik]
wer was und es hat mit grillen nichts zu
tun dass sie traurig aus
aber der produktentwickler ist ja auch
noch längst nicht fertig schritt eins
zur grill optik aus der retorte paprika
farbe
schritt 2 brandspuren nur eine sache von
sekunden
[Musik]
fehlt nur noch das grill muster aber für
sebastian lege gibt es nichts was sich
nicht im schnellverfahren imitieren
lässt zeit es geld
entschuldige aber ich zeige ich dir mal
wie geflügel aussieht wenn es ganz
normal ohne theater zubereitet wird
und wenn ich das jetzt vergleiche was ja
nicht wirklich vergleichbar ist
läge ahnt es schon das luxus und
schmeckt auch ohne wirz hilfe lecker
[Musik]
so einfach wie es aussieht ist es nicht
denn ohne die erfahrung eines
grillprofis kann das auch schief gehen
[Musik]
ja aber ich sage mal das problem ist ja
meistens bei seinem ganzen team
sensorisch oft die brust zu trocken und
die schenkel noch nicht durch aber es
geht nun mal nur um den geschmack
einfach das schmeckt mir was wirklich
ist drohen saftige so lecker gehört auch
zum gstaad schlägt erstmal nach
glücklichen huhn
[Musik]
ob das mit flüssig würze auf der punkte
industrie hähnchen da mithalten kann
sebastian nägel ist gespannt wie
sternekoch frank buchholz sein billig
huhn findet
[Musik]
wir überlegen jetzt bei mir hefeextrakt
ohne salz drin dann raucharoma drinnen
nicht schlecht besser als ich erwartet
habe und dass ich ganz ehrlich sagen
früher ja nicht schlecht und ich sage
mal der durchschnittsdeutsche denn
natürlich sehr fleisch lastig ist auch
in seiner ernährung muss auf solche
produkte zurückgreifen
dementsprechend auch also müssen tut er
schon mal gar nicht mehr wenn du das
sein lassen würdest du dann hast du auch
nicht das problem dass du so oft ein
schlechtes gewissen als wenn du
einschläfst und dann dem lieben gott
noch nicht gross war gerne aber ich
möchte doch lieber in den himmel
spitzenqualität hat auch ihren preis
doch günstige produkte für geringere
ansprüche verkauften sich einfach besser
und dank würze hat das billig hohen
sogar dem sternekoch erstaunlich gut
geschmeckt
[Musik]
was sind eure würz und marinade tricks
auf dem grill sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
lebensmittel wissen wollt schaut die
nächsten zwei clips und abonniert die
zdf besser essen
[Musik]